i guess we're on good morning
so
you know i was uh
actually i didn't sleep very well last
night so i was lying there thinking
about different things
and one of the things that i thought
about is
you know
oh i have to turn so
there we go
so
you know when i was uh in school
uh we had french in montreal montreal in
those days was
very much a divided city you had a
million english speakers and two million
french speakers and uh they kind of
stuck to themselves
it was known as the two solitudes which
is not the case today if you go to
montreal downtown montreal if you're in
you know you
go out for breakfast or you're meeting
with people since a lot of the time you
don't know if it's an anglophone
speaking french or francophone speaking
english
montreal has become a genuinely
bilingual city
at least in the downtown area i don't
know there are probably if you go out to
the west island you'll meet people who
only speak english and if you go to
other parts of montreal you'll meet
people who only speak french but but
overwhelmingly in the area that i go to
i get this impression of a very vibrant
bilingual city
um
but there i was in school
and we did french in front of just a
subject like trigonometry you know we
had no particular interest in it
we did what we had to do to pass
and now today i'm learning my 19th and
20th language now i want to be careful i
have learned languages that i can't
operate in right now like greek or
romanian but but they're there they're
there somewhere they're there in link
content that i've used words that i've
learned
and i can revive them
if i were going off to romania it
wouldn't take me long to get up to a
level same with the greek
polish whatever
so
what has changed
and what has changed in my mind is that
you know it
it's now to my mind it's become normal
to speak many languages
and in fact i have to confess not
confess but
um
recollect that when i started these
videos back whatever 10 or so years ago
uh and when i wrote my book
which was which described how in the
course of my professional career i had
learned nine languages i was i was 60 at
the time i had learned nine languages
for a variety of reasons related to my
work to my travels to my interests but i
had learned nine languages
i'm now approaching 20.
um and at that time the book was called
the way of the linguist because if you
look up an english dictionary and this
gets some people upset but the number
one definition of the word linguist in
an english language dictionary i don't
care whether it's oxford or
merriam-webster or what it is
is going to be someone who speaks many
languages so that historically
in english the word linguist has meant
someone who's adept at languages who
speaks many languages he speaks
languages like a violinist plays the
violin a pianist plays the piano a
linguist speaks languages well
but there always was this other word
first of all there was this other
definition of linguist as someone who
studies linguistics and that's a much
more recent meaning for that term
because linguistics is a relatively
recent
field of study
but there's also another term for
someone who speaks many languages and
that is polyglot which comes from the
greek many tongues
uh and i would say that certainly 10
years ago and maybe even today outside
of this
our area of people who like languages
a lot of english speakers don't even
know what the word polyglot means
the word polyglot is much more common in
other languages where the word linguist
is not used to mean someone who speaks
many languages but the word polyglot is
used
that's true in french and spanish
in russian and so forth
but
i am
now more and more
prone to use the word polyglot rather
than the word linguist because even in
my mind linguist
is someone who speaks three or four
languages
it's an arbitrary it's the way i take it
but when you hear the word polyglot you
think of five or six or more languages
that's the way i interpret it now some
other people may have other terms
there's also this term hyperglot or
hyper polyglot which i don't like at all
i think you're
you're either bilingual or multilingual
or a polyglot or whatever
and never has to become easier or
or more
nothing to speak many languages
because the even compared to 10 12 years
ago let alone when i was back in school
it's just so much easier
and i think we should celebrate this
celebrate the idea that
first of all in school
they should teach many languages
they should teach many languages with
the goal of teaching comprehension
not with the goal of testing people on
whether they can get the subjunctive
right or whether they can get this or
that fine part of grammar right but
rather expose people to a lot of
languages from different language
families
expose them to these languages so they
can at least get some comprehension some
taste of these languages and that might
then induce them to learn the language
later on
and you sometimes hear people say well
in the future we won't need to learn
languages because we can uh rely on some
form of artificial intelligence or
something
and i don't believe that at all i think
the other uh is true that the all of the
advances in technology which i mentioned
before and i might mention again today
make it
easier to learn languages
uh so that you know if i'm sitting in a
plane
as i was was the case flying from uh
iguazu to rio and the gentleman beside
me is uh paraguayan but actually
of ukrainian origin and we speak in
ukrainian i wouldn't do that through my
iphone
where i would speak into the iphone and
out comes the translation and he can
listen to it and we pass it back and
forth we would not have that
conversation
we'd say hello and go back to reading or
whatever we were doing
i'm learning my persian right now and
i'm i'm genuine you know there are times
when you get the sense that you're
making progress and i'm making progress
in my persian
and i'm reviewing right now i'm doing
the asamil lessons that i imported into
link
uh where i i took the audio which i got
with the book that i bought and then i
put it on the vocalmatic example of
technology which transcribed the whole
thing for me
minus punctuation which is unfortunate
they do offer punctuation for english
transcriptions but not for
pharmacy if i feel like it i could go in
there and put in the punctuation but i
haven't done so but at least i'm
listening and i'm going through the
lessons and i also have the book and so
here again i'm multi-platform i'm doing
it in the book paper and i'm also doing
it on link and listening and stuff and i
really feel i'm making progress
and when i go back to vancouver where
there's lots of personal speakers in
north vancouver west vancouver
i will use it um sales people and
other people that i come across i
wouldn't do that with my iphone and say
look at me i can speak into my iphone in
english and out comes persian
the shopkeeper would tell me to go away
whereas if i come in i even have a
barber
who's person
and so i can be sitting in the barber
chair
and speaking to her in persian
i wouldn't do that with my iphone
which reminds me about the way i had my
hair cut and uh
so i went to the local barber here and
he had his air pods in his ear while
cutting my hair
so i said can i put my air pods in my
ear while you cut my hair he said fine
so i was able to listen to persian while
he was cutting my hair
and he was very careful when he cut
around my ears that he didn't dislodge
the air pod so with all of that i think
we should have more recognition of this
idea that we can all be polyglots we can
all learn many languages
uh
you know with the amount of travel that
goes on the internet accessing
interesting content
the you know online
dictionaries uh text-to-speech automatic
transcription link
uh
other you know facilities that are at
their language exchange websites and
stuff everybody can learn three or four
or five languages and i get extremely
annoyed with people who always say well
you obviously have a talent you know
like the number of people who say yeah i
was never any good at languages yeah i
have no talent for languages yeah i
can't learn languages you're lucky you
have a talent for languages
i don't believe that not for a second
because if you go to countries like say
sweden or singapore everybody speaks at
least two languages and don't tell me
that
that everyone in north america has no
talent for lava or that the majority of
people in north america have no talent
for languages and that the majority of
people in sweden or
singapore or ethiopia have some kind of
gene that makes them better at learning
languages i don't believe that for a
second you just have to do it you just
have to spend the time
and of course
a lot of the traditional methods of
instruction where they try to teach you
grammar up front when you have no sense
of the language no previous experience
with the language
and you get all these explanations
that are that are meaningless
meaningless and then you have to be
worried about getting them wrong on the
exam and stuff and they may not click in
until two or three or five years later
so i think part of it is how they're
taught and it seems to instill in people
a sense that you know unless you have
some special talent
you can't learn languages i don't
believe that i believe that everyone has
the potential to be a polyglot i think
being a polycloth is a wonderful thing
you can go and connect with all these
different cultures uh i'm not gonna go
so far as to say that it would eliminate
a lot of the nonsense that happens in
the world i don't think it would
but it certainly broadens
one's perspective to have
more than one language and possibly more
than two languages three or four
languages
it makes you
aware of worlds outside your own little
narrow world and so we should have an
international day of
polyglots or i don't even like the word
polyglottery international polyglot
day
we should have that i don't know when
today is whatever it is march
20
what is it today anyway the 22nd
maybe march 22nd is pretty close to the
beginning of spring
no ruse as it is in iran
so
that's really all i wanted to say and i
will now
uh
have a look at whatever questions might
have arrived
so
i found a really funny mistake type in
one of link's turkish mini stories you
should email it in yes please do i mean
we rely on
people i'm not i can't speak turkish and
we need people to tell us if there are
areas we're very happy to correct them
we would go back to the person who did
the mini story because sometimes people
at any rate please let us know thank you
what is your advice for traveling i'd
love to go from where i live to europe
but obviously the cost is a turnip
what is my advice i mean
you look for deals i mean you're not
going to go by boat so you have to fly
so you look for deals all kinds of
airlines offer deals
and then there are people who travel
cheaply couch surfing and you have to
get on the internet and connect with
communities of people who travel
and who don't have and don't want to
spend a lot of money
oh alpine link you can correct it okay
no uh if p if someone is a native
speaker in a language
we can give them an edit pencil not
everyone has it because we can't just
have people at random changing our
lessons but if we we can choose to make
someone
an editor and they then can go in and
make the changes themselves
uh that's for alpine link
did you see that
okay
hey what's fresh
ah
so this is again this business of
editing
a lesson okay oh you don't have premier
what can be a story without evidence can
also be dismissed without evidence can
you learn chinese in one year with hard
work yes
i did it
okay
if i'm going to go back to the languages
that i haven't
you know studied it for a long time
if something takes me there so i'm going
to be visiting ukraine i'll sort of
freshen up my russian and ukrainian
uh i like italian german all these
languages and if i have if i happen to
come across an article
you know i'll read it in that language
but i i won't be making any special
effort to sort of raise the level okay
tim donor i believe i've seen him i
think he's an outstanding polyglot i
don't remember that well
do you think people are giving a talent
language is faster have an easier time
i mean it's like anything some people
might be better in some aspects of
learning a language than others some
might learn it faster some slower
some might pronounce better but these
are not significant differences we can
all learn
brazil i love your videos today i'm
learning mandarin thanks a lot good luck
to you
uh
i have recently become interested in
arabic sometime in the future for
business purposes would it be most
smart to learn msa or regional dialect
what dialect do people in the uae use
you know if you have a particular
business reason for learning arabic and
it involves
dealing with people in the united arab
emirates then i would learn their
regional dialect
my interest in arabic is more i want to
be able to read newspapers i want to
understand podcasts i want to have a
sort of a base in the language that
would enable me
then
at some point i was going to be spending
a lot of time in lebanon or morocco or
egypt then i could go and focus in on
that language
yeah i appreciate yes if we give up
learning languages because of
machines then we can give up sports
right
no i don't know any free platform where
i can chat with native japanese but
again you just have to google
oh it's good man the panda likes my
haircut
thank you every so often i have to cut
my hair it takes a lot of time to learn
to make more time for young people to
actually learn them as school what do
you mean see this is a question of
actually learn them
uh i think we need to expose them to
them give them interesting things to
listen to and read in movies and videos
and point out how some of these
languages work without forcing them to
perform on tests
and so if you if i actually learn them
in school you mean that get them to
speak them properly in school
i don't necessarily agree that that's
where the emphasis should be
what are your opinions on mr clarkson's
rants about you this is a guy who's
located somewhere in thailand that
constantly rants calls me
i don't know a fake and all kind of
stuff i think he is uh
has some uh psychological problems
ah dear steve what is your friend okay
i'm 50 is too old
i'm 53 is that too old to learn you in
several languages says cashew paul well
i'm 73
and since the age of 60
i have learned nine languages
so i don't think you're too old
we now know science knows that our
brains our neurons remain plastic
we just have to activate them we have to
do something give them work to do and
they will respond
why do you think some people get
offended when you speak their language
i've never had that reaction i haven't
had people get offended yeah you have to
be careful like
if someone say um and i'm guilty of this
sometimes like here in palm springs
you can see people whose name is
jorge or pedro
and he even speaks with a bit of a
spanish accent and he's originally from
mexico
he doesn't necessarily want me to speak
to him in spanish he's
here he's an american now he's speaking
english he's working in english he wants
to speak english so he doesn't want you
to say oh you're a mexican i can speak
spanish and similarly sometimes in
vancouver if you have a waiter in a
restaurant
and they're obviously chinese uh but if
you speak them in chinese they may come
back in english because you know what
you think my child might you think my
english is no good so those are the
kinds of things other than that i
haven't seen
people become you know get offended if
you speak their language
i'm going full time with learning
chinese do you have any tips for not
burning out
uh just keep it varied just keep it
varied
okay what do you think it was that
transformed montreal into a bilingual
area it was the
coming to power of a of a nationalist
government
a quebecois government that said you
know we want to be masters in our own
house because in up until 1960
um
you know the english speakers controlled
the economy the english speakers had all
the good jobs
uh education was controlled by the
catholic church
and the
the uh
the liberals at that time they came to
power and they said we're gonna change
that we're gonna have a minister of
education we're gonna get the church out
of the not out of education we're gonna
take over the primary responsibility for
education
we're going to make sure that we don't
just educate
you know lawyers and accountants
and
notaries and priests
we're going to educate engineers and
business people
and we're going to have some rather
in many sense unfair language laws that
we're going to force people
to have signs in french because you were
in this town montreal and you're hardly
aware that it was a french town so many
of those laws were a bit unfair
but the net result was i think uh
positive although it caused a lot of
english-speaking montrealers to leave or
english-speaking quebecers to leave
quebec so there was an economic cost to
it
but they did
essentially establish the
primary position of french in
montreal so an english speaker in
montreal needs to have french
in order to work there
so it became a necessity so french
became important
um
i'm doing fine
i'm not sure
wait how second
can a russian native speaker learn
german in one year up to b2
i think so i mean it's all a matter of
how you go about it
and how much time you put in every day i
mean if i learn chinese up to b2 in one
year but full time
despite the difficulty of learning
chinese characters
uh definitely a russian native speaking
larger but lots of listening and reading
lots of listening reading don't get hung
up on
you know
nailing down the grammar the grammar
will gradually come to it you can review
it from time to time
but
it'll all fall into place if you give
yourself enough exposure to the language
and when you speak just talk don't
second-guess yourself
uh don't worry about how you sound just
go for it
okay i said speak while you need to
speak a lot how far can you get with
speaking to yourself
i have never been big
on speaking to myself
some people do it
try it i mean obviously it's it's a form
of
of output
but i think it's it's better to find
people to talk to
uh hi steve do you watch netflix using
audio description for the blind
i haven't done that
uh
something to do now look into that but i
don't spend a lot of time in front of
the television so i really can't comment
okay
here uh i can't match my links what is
the best way of reviewing links okay i
don't try to review all my links i have
far too many of them i review them
typically as i
turn the page or move on to a new lesson
i don't expect to remember anything i
don't try to memorize them i don't spend
a lot of time on review
uh it's just another form of exposure
uh it's sort of a concentrated exposure
of words and phrases say in a lesson
that you were having trouble with but
but don't hang on to it leave it
just just do it a little bit don't worry
about how much it it helped you and just
move on
salute
hello i'm currently learning two
languages simultaneous german japanese
is it a good idea to do so it can be if
that's what you like doing uh my
experience with farsi and or at least
persian and and arabic is
it's an interesting experience i would
be further along in each one of them if
i were working on them you know if i
were concentrating but this way i'm able
to do a little bit in each
it keeps things fresh
uh but there's a certain period of
catching up again like i had a
discussion with my persian tutor on a
wednesday having done nothing but arabic
for four days and i was really
struggling
so
i think you have to experiment but it's
not impossible it depends
how you study and
and
and what you like to do
have you ever considered learning
vietnamese well i was in vietnam for
a week
so i tried to learn up some vietnamese
before going there i got a phrase book
got less i bought some books i listened
i basically was unable to do anything
the only word i came away with from
vietnam was come on
which i think is
i can't remember now thank you
uh but it sounds like come on so
so it takes a lot of work but i can't
imagine that vietnamese would be more
difficult than chinese in fact should be
easier because you don't have to learn
characters
how many hours a day do you devote to
language learning well
you know i think i get in an hour of
listening and probably another hour 45
minutes of reading and linking
is it possible because it should be to
an alignment just by listening and not
reading
well uh if you just listen uh i find i
can't understand a thing
so i have to read in order to see what
the words were
uh
you know
i would say no i would say no
yeah
how do you know what the words are
unless somebody explains them to you
i am using link to learn slovak reading
a lot as this similar check which you
speak what in your opinion is the best
way to ever get to fluency with so many
suffixes to learn
well i mean it's you know i i think that
uh
we i
you know i like the many stories we have
them in slovak uh
if you want to get to that
you know through the many stories you
can go and buy an ebook and an audiobook
and work with that and it's just a lot
of exposure and don't focus so much on
specific
grammatical issues like suffixes um
they'll eventually seem clear to you a
lot of the stuff that seems so very
difficult
and
you know
insurmountable at first becomes easy
with time
sandy moonstone teacher i see you can't
read mandarin now what would brought
what i do read mandarin what would be
the reason for that
did sandy moonstone send me a
message in
mandarin anyway i'm not going to bother
with that
um
have you ever considered himself
planning to move
to montreal after college i'm hoping my
friends from school improves
rapidly once i get speaking to give it
first so far i've been practicing at
quebec by accident in french yeah i mean
we'll learn the accent that's
most uh
useful for
us
okay
okay mastering cases in russia
it's one of these things that in time
you get better habits at obviously when
we are
reading
or listening not knowing the cases is
less of a problem because we can tell
the meaning from the context in most
cases not always
but so that listening and reading helps
us get a grasp on the cases
but
what i do is
you know
occasionally consultant
with uh
many many explanations and exceptions
etc that govern the use of cases
uh i save phrases in link that have
these cases i remember when i was doing
it i would tag them so i would review
you know just the certain case
um
sometimes uh if i'm if i have a book
where they have a lot of questions that
are asking for a certain case then i'll
look at the answers at the back of the
book you need some sort of concentrated
exposure to them so that you develop the
right habits so that when you speak you
can use them correctly when i get to
ukraine i will be using them incorrectly
and slowly through a lot of exposure i
will get a little bit better but i won't
get a hundred percent
how can you make being a polyglot your
source of income
i'm not aware of how you can
uh korean yeah i mean i i worked at it
for a while and and uh it's a language
that i feel i'm i'm on the sort of
threshold of being able to speak well
but i'm not there yet so i'm probably
somewhere between b1 and
on that long road between b1 and b2
uh how did you fall in love with
learning languages
well
it's just fun it's just fun uh
it's it's it's fun i guess two things
one is it's the fun of discovering
something new and everything that comes
with the language
and the second thing is that once you
realize that you can do it then you want
to do more of it
greetings from latvia your inspiration i
want to learn several languages know my
native language learned at school
russian and english starting on my own
rosary rose
latvia i visited riga uh i really
enjoyed it
um great town nice little park in the
middle of town and all of that
good luck to you and your mandarin dandy
moon
okay so what do you want me to do with
that does link have any polish tutors or
should i just search on the internet i
don't think we do uh it's a bit of a
chicken and egg situation i would go to
italki there's some excellent
tutors there evalina is one that i used
who's very good
particularly
[Music]
you know what is it
what do you think is better better to to
you know be
sort of poor in many languages or
master a few it doesn't matter it's it's
it's up to each individual if i'm
before i certainly didn't master
romanian or greek i got very interested
in wanting to discover arabic and then
persian i go where the moon takes me
i look like his grandfather
how do you get more how do you get more
vocabulary use link it's an ideal tool
for a tool for that
[Music]
how much time do you spend finding
compelling content it's an issue
and i think i think we've got to do a
better job of presenting people with the
content and making it easier for people
to find stuff of interest to them
b1 to b2 is a long road do you approach
different topics in different languages
would you read for example news about
chinese use relations in both languages
look for perspective in a neutral
country's language
well i wouldn't read specifically about
chinese u.s relations for example i
might be interested in history or i
might be interested in following the
news so any news item could be about any
subject
and
i mean necessarily if if you're uh
in a certain language like if i'm fall
if i'm doing my arabic and i'm doing i'm
trying to follow events at the you know
podcast of husband cat or al jazeera
it's going to tend to be more about the
middle east
and it's interesting to get a middle
eastern perspective
on events in the middle east which we
normally just
hear about through our own media
what is your opinion on switching to
only barely comprehensible input when
there's a lack of intermediate content
and the beginner content becomes too
easy
i deal with that all the time i'm
struggling with that in arabic and i
sort of
you know i sort of switch back and forth
from sort of the easier content which
might be a simile or in persian because
the arabic is not very good
uh or my many stories and then
fighting through these podcasts
gradually gaining more vocabulary and
after a while i find it too tiring and i
go back to the easy
you kind of have to mix the two
uh what do you think of dashan okay i
have
i think i've seen a video of him i don't
know much about him but i do know that
he is very very fluent in mandarin
chinese as a canadian who's
lived in china for quite a while and
he's a comedian on television and it's
sort of confirmation amongst the many
many other people that you can learn a
language to
a very high level as an adult
azerbaijan i'd like
another place i'd like to visit
uh steve please turn on subtitles in
your live speed so i can follow in
spanish whatever and practice at the
same time
i don't understand i don't know that i'm
the one
who does that i'll look into it
and um
okay
live stream hello sir i'm really big fan
okay
thank you
uh
now
enjoy your mio
i mean we have
i'm not sure what this person is looking
for here we have chinese material at
link
i think we have
cantonese mandarin in simplified and
mandarin in traditional characters
so please look again
uh do you think assimil is a good
language learning resource you know it's
a starter book like any other it
progresses very quickly in some
languages the content was interesting
and good russian was a good one
the persian is a good one in some it
gets to be they're trying to be too cute
sometimes with their stories
persian they give you a glossary like
the words which in some of their
languages they don't they just give you
the translation which i don't like i
find a lot of their explanatory notes
are just a distraction i don't even look
at them so to me there's nothing special
okay i'm gonna call it here and uh thank
you a little shorter today and we'll see
if
the united nations establishes a world
polyglot today bye for now